all right I think most people are there
now but I'll just walk through these
steps in case you're not sure how one of
these questions works right what have I
done well they've given me this and I've
said look differentiate it see what
happens right so here is what I get -
what's up differentiated which is
convenient isn't it so I wonder if that
was something close to what you guessed
you're like oh yes that's exactly what I
was thinking
I wonder be able to guess it which is
why we really expected to memorize this
result okay but having been given it you
know how to differentiate it's just
that's just a chain rule
this is chain rule plus a product rule
right because that song you and that's
me and it all comes out in the wash
which is nice so what I do from line
three alive for I'm integrating both
sides with respect to X that's what gets
rid of the derivative and it adds the
constant in on this side but of course
if I'm actually working on a definite
integral I don't need to worry about the
cluster when I'm evaluating but just to
make sure it actually works okay what
happened well what's what's gonna happen
in here so all evaluate at the upper
bound and it's deflected from value
meaning for long time right so what am I
going to get here this is my first one
so square root of 1 minus 1 is 0
hey plus 1 times sine inverse of 1 will
come back to him in a second okay - all
right we'll towards the lower balance
yeah so I'm going to 0 so this is the
square root of 1 minus 0 which is 1 and
then plus 0 lots of will actually care
what the right is because it's Deever
okay so what's sine inverse of 1 that's
pi - okay good so that's a relief right
we did actually come back to this out a
geometric argument landed us on the same
conclusion as if you actually knew what
the premiere function was so that's a
relief
now let's do the next one because it's
it's a little bit you can still be a
little more careful right
okay so where did I go - okay now being
that this is my graphing question right
by the time you sort of get to the
agency we saw that these questions now
you probably don't need to actually
enjoy out anything but I'm still going
to draw out on the side here a nice
rough diagram so I can work out and not
get confused what my boundaries are
that's the most important part
okay so what does this look like here is
same as this one okay so half is yes so
there's the actual area than I'm after
so the important thing is okay now when
I turn this into a regular sine graph
right like so where is this area it's
here right nestled up against the y-axis
okay so what X values what new upper and
lower boundaries am I gonna have there
won't be 0 and 1/2 what's it going to be
what angle corresponds to that it's
policies right which actually makes
sense like even if you look at it you
doing that that's apply on to right so
plan 6 it even it's sort of to scale if
you've thrown a reasonable you can guess
that that's okay so now I can
immediately write the equivalent sort of
flip dislike here right I want my
rectangle which is around it and then I
want to add a new integral new definite
rule enough for me so what's the area of
the rectangle in this case
yes is plan 12 right I'm gonna go ahead
and write the whole like the actual
length and breadth just so I don't
confuse myself later on and I can track
down an error if that's that's awesome
O'Hara then subtract and now this new
interval I'm forming like you told me
it's from naught to PI on six now from
there it works just the same so this
might be Santa's punt well this is going
to be minus cos x which is double
negative from naught to PI on six all
right
yes because that'll be minus cos PI on
12 okay we're going to you what is close
Clancy's that's that's for 3m to write
and then cos of 0 is just 1 this is
minus 1 so that's it actually is there's
not much else to do because they just
kind of messy you got it
you got an integer and a third and the
transit never know mark which don't mix
okay yeah you decide to get the hang of
it right but some of the areas are
trickier than others so the next one
that I've got three I'll show you a
couple of tricks to do this one because
there's two four ways to go which are
equally valid but it's probably one
which is better than the other
okay so what I'm asking you do is I
think it's true it's a negative one
okay so what does cause it must look
like that's the one which is all above
the axis right so it's looking like this
okay so there's minus 1 minus root 3 on
2 is like 0.8 608 7 or something like
that so it's pretty close here right -
true - 302 and I'm gonna go all the way
out some alliances so this is the area
ok yeah this is actually worth drawing
out right when I convert this from a
cause even best kind of diagram to a
regular cause kind of diagram where is
the area so this is the corresponding
domain of cause okay
where when is the area bottom waist -
route 302 it's up this way down here
right okay and there's 0 so the actual
area I'm interested in is here
that's not very straight but you get
doing ok for regular cause okay so the
area I need to subtract right is this
area here right I can get that rectangle
and then I subtract the green area ok so
you have to be careful though because
the green area is negative yes
so take note of that one of the new
bounds going to be sorry actually let's
let's take a step back
what's the area of the rectangle first
that's that's the big thing that will
cut out the green area what is the area
that I do what's the height the height
is just root three on two
okay now what's the width of that
rectangle it's all the way from he up to
whatever that value is now what are
handy things about this right is that
you know maybe you try to work out on
this diagram what it's equal to
but you can actually come back to this
diagram because because we've restricted
the domain of cause to Atlanta cos
inverse specifically so that have you
taken X value had caused him most of
that you will get one answer one hits
early right so this Y value ought to
correspond to that X belly right so when
you put cos inverse of minus root 3 over
2 into your calculator cuz your
calculators think okay sir you should
get by pod six so my diagram is horribly
off scale because that's let's just okay
so five if that's not a square root sign
that's I'm fine it's 150 degrees right
that's how high you're going on so
that's what this this measurement here
is five five on six okay
so what's the area of my rectangle its
length times yeah be careful here need
the previous questions like this one
right I subtracted an area okay
of course I subtracted an area because
you know I was trying to take a
difference right but I shouldn't
subtract an area this time why not
that's right because it's already under
the axis right I actually want to add
whatever this integral is because this
integral will be negative suppose you I
suppose you hood
suppose you can do it's doing it's
having much the same effect but I think
you're better off looking draw your
diagram properly saying that's a good to
be a negative result so I'm gonna
all right what's the integral what are
my upper and lower bounds I've already
worked out the up and round what's the
little bounce okay and in some senses
that's that's really all hog work right
we can go from there okay now I do just
want to draw out the fact that because
all of these are all these trig
functions right they all kind of the
same function just moved around or
flipped upside down all of that kind of
thing okay so when you look at this you
know you might be thinking crows kind of
read boundaries right can anyone think
of it easier said about go and easy a
pair of boundaries that would give us
the same area look at that shape down
there what could you choose yes okay
let's think about that so this shape
down here right this part of cause okay
what it corresponds to is this part of
site okay it's just it's just upside
down okay now what's that distance there
from PI R 2 to 5 / 6 that's 90 to 150
yeah it's 60 degrees or PI 3 radians
right so this is the same as going from
0 to PI on 3 that area there of sign
okay so you could just as equally
they've notice it's positive rather than
negative okay so if you don't like this
okay you could just as fairly have said
let's subtract the area from 0 to PI on
three of sine X okay the hopeful you
might think that's kind of weird why we
the question to that closed universe and
not sign well we kind of artificially
imposing on these other functions anyway
this doesn't come from the original
function right we just know that this
area is equivalent to what we're trying
to subtract just like this is okay so
long as you enjoy your diagram well you
can actually pick whatever equivalent
area you like so long as it's actually
gonna give you the right now
and sometimes remote for instance rather
zero there it'll give you some slightly
nicer to evaluate function that